I was down in Venice I was biking riding
my bike and biker turn on the club well
Venice is a strong chapter so you were
the wrong colors down there Papa well
because that might be because I'm thin
boy and thin boy Beach cruise then boy
beat screw so you know you're in the
boys club where the same boy comes to
you the gay boy bites do we call it the
thin boy coaster so it's it's a Chinese
are us then you looking the captive gays
don't know we're the thin boy thi and
and help too much applause marking where
the thin boy coasters hurt can you guys
ride by and go ahead well well it's
funny because as I was down on
Washington Boulevard in the beach as I'm
riding my very gay well my very sort of
its way it's a beach at one speed
there's a once it's a beach cruiser in
fact the guy looked amigos they don't
want speed I go okay yeah dude I guess
it's a 100 feet cruisers are though okay
it's like a mime for Mongols Mongol
California Chapter they shelf their
choice
there's just hey no they did not really
oh that's surprised no except for - well
no the Mongols acknowledge or think bad
job believe that I was in Venice I don't
believe that the Mongol bike while you
were sick though huh oh yeah those go
right there they're thick rough looking
guys just hanging those sitting on their
bikes polished very well usually at the
whaler
they were across from the whaler oh well
know that Calvin that's that's right
that tells that they were across from
cows and they would they were at that
other bar cross and they were just
sitting not even there on the street
just having sip and look that look like
sipping out of hot paper cups you go
like this
hey boys sweet bikes mmm you're getting
dirty and yellow boy I sure didn't know
I did feel like I was like hey as I rode
by like these men on their bikes and I'm
on my beasts cruiser and I I glanced
over and then I looked away because I
just fell of course she I felt like I'm
not gonna felt like a bit of a [ __ ]
yeah I'm the one man I do salute him hey
guys my beach cruiser that should be the
theme of your bike club well a suck yeah
yeah well [ __ ] I don't need you being a
moment
don't be the head of my marketing Pro
Beach clarity sake beach cruisers and
dick sucks
when a sakya thin boy will come to you
thin boy coaster club
yeah mukya hidden boy coaster club while
you relax let us sake
well suck you and then just but we take
the easy road we take the back road huh
huh we take the back road we take mud
don't scare us
just yeah a little mud never hurt
anybody I mean you're like this covered
in mud that's all I'm spit ball yeah
now it's grease the boys up won't you
grease the wheels I'm not doing that
I'll stir bites no I'm I'm the promised
butan 53 mold so the problem is what I
told you well I realized when I was
getting old I realized I was getting
older when gay men stopped looking at me
that's when you know you go there's
couple twinks still take you for a ride
old man
maybe daddy maybe they got a daddy yeah
there was no daddy compound but it's
rich slim to vanish all right no I think
you should go the right club dude I can
pay bills there are guys that'll open up
oh yeah I understand
open that peach right well shaved up the
well shaved up here comes a thin boy
bike club you light up your ass and and
and I and I demand my whistle be clean I
demand because I may be the president of
the thin boys coaster club you're really
pushing this hey but you got a hey you
need to go to the abbey and just see how
things go ride your gay beach cruiser up
there and just kind of have a positive
attitude wet your lips and see how the
night goes
just be a guy they look like peewee
football players I want to ride I want
to ride sometimes I just want to get off
dude right I want to get on a bike I
really do I might start [ __ ] mountain
biking with you well if you're gonna
smoke an Saturday morning the clubs get
together the spoke in Chapter maybe I'll
do that and I might be bringing up the
rear because I don't ride a lot that
ain't the time to start at one more
advanced you really come to more events
for your first try I don't know dude
okay maybe I'll make a quick appearance
and say what's up you guys up mall
jerseys
hold on fresh out okay hold on maybe
I'll hold the flag and go like this
ready set go
we're gonna do what you know hold the
water flow when we come by and we grab
it
oh my wrist instead of water it'll be
vodka suckers nope [ __ ] you
that's that bad member there oh we can
specialize throwing down the big boy
moves thanks for educating Kalin how the
fish boys roll dude that specialized the
company a specialized I'd like a bike
hmm and I want my son to have one he's
eight I want to take him bike riding
through a real problem what I want to
bite my soul wants a bike that's not
what the club is dude but I want I want
a soul is this a charity yeah no I want
to represent you'll have money no I have
not mine no by my eyes you owe me a bike
okay but I'm just saying I don't know
what kind of bike to get so maybe
specialized could help me and if they
have one pop we can help you but
specialized probably knows what's good
for my body I'm 511 170 all muscle you
know you're just not you know I hate to
be shitty gonna hurt sales come on man
that's a [ __ ] unfair thing you don't
want to say why your membership is
revoked that's not fair why man great
shape you know this you know I'm in
great shape you saw me leaping dude the
the Ferrari or the Porsche gt2 of all
bikes yeah it's a specialized levo turbo
SL that they had on their side I don't
need that I just need a starter bike get
me a starter bike then I think you
should get huffy I'm not getting a
[ __ ] huffy now I want to worry about
what is specialized they're a good
company no I'm [ __ ] I want to
represent specialized no yeah nope what
about the beginners club yet to go
killing the [ __ ] horses you're
talking about [ __ ] let's call it old
starters mature starters 6,000 the turbo
expensive leave oh it's like 13 grand I
think Jesus Christ isn't the one that we
were looking at last time with a gold
chain mm-hmm oh it's an expensive begin
one are you gonna be another guy who's
gonna have 15 bikes now oh yeah got to
do it right
got the stable bro oh you like horses
check out my face what I do
check out my stage and come by and I
take one of your bikes you're stealing
I'll do it in a heartbeat oh the promise
what
small hold on it too small oh but I can
lower the seat
no but the shocks are set for guys 260
pounds the whole thing set up for my
site really you can't oh and it was
jumping on the trampoline yesterday
heard and that trampoline wasn't me and
I was an Olympic trampoline boy oh boy
that was a crater the thing was smooth
yeah grats buddy thanks pal big boy
Murch drops Friday Batman then boy March
10th boy Moritz come in thin boy Cruiser
club then boy Cruiser club so no money
that would sell them start a company
thin boy Cruiser Club where do you buy
just biked around banisters cruise
around guys
I'll be around I'll be out there I'll be
out there man I'll see out there right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]